foreign
in Houston what's up Lynn
hey how are you partying how are you
I'm doing good thanks for taking my call
of course thanks for calling what are
you doing what's up
um so my question is
how do I learn to trust my husband again
and to be vulnerable in my marriage to
move forward after discovering lies and
secrets that my husband has been keeping
for years
I'm sorry how long have y'all been
married
we've been married nine years okay
tell me tell me the secrets what's
what'd you find
so in 2020 we were refinancing our house
and I found a large debt on our debt to
wealth ratio statement
and when I question my husband about it
I found out that he had been hiding
about sixty thousand dollars in credit
card debt since 2016. was he spending
that money on
he had tried to start a side business or
a construction business after he had
gotten laid off
and
um I didn't know that he wasn't making
enough to cover his expenses and so he
was just putting things on credit cards
and not telling me about it
and interest would hit and it would get
bigger and interested hit get bigger and
just snowballed out of control how long
did this last
um it's
he had it under control he uh
gotten a line of credit he was working
to pay it off it was maybe going within
18 months you know not to worry about it
the next year in 2021 we tried to buy
some land and through that process I
found out that he did not have an earth
control
and he was continuing to rack up more
debt
I'm calling bullcrap on the business
expense there's something else going on
here
like I I would ask for an itemized list
report of the things that were purchased
on those on those on those balance
sheets whether it's the line of credit
purchases or on the credit card
statements
sixty thousand dollars because otherwise
there'd be assets that you could see
like a truck or a tractor or a bunch of
tools
mm-hmm
right nobody would say if he would he
was moving over to a zero interest
credit card then he wouldn't get it paid
off in time and then all the back
interest was hit I I know but you're
talking sixty thousand dollars
there's something else at play is he has
he is he seeing somebody
well
not that I'm aware of at that time
but now
oh
so okay so he's seeing somebody now
well about six months ago I found out
that he was having a well he claimed an
emotional sir he says nothing physical
happened with a co-worker
here's why here's why you can't trust
because you know in your guts you're not
getting the full story
don't you
yes you know it you've known this dude
for more than a decade right
yeah and you know you're not getting the
full story how long
20 years
you know you're not getting the full
story
why haven't you demanded the full story
you haven't because you're scared why
well I tried I I honestly like when I
found out about this bowl
I I hold on talk directly into your
phone for me
oh sorry can you hear me yeah
when I found out about this girl I I
tried to demand the whole story
and
like really begged for it
I I feel like I just maybe got the full
story of about a month ago
Maybe
I I don't know at this point I don't
know what to believe anymore
which is why I'm calling you
so
I I
he's not on the phone to defend himself
and so I can throw grenades at him all
day long I don't like to be that guy I
don't think he's telling you the truth
and I think there's something else
usually when somebody racks up this kind
of debt it's one of two things and it
does happen in construction so I want to
give that there's usually significant
assets
there's big purchases that were made
like I'm starting a construction company
or a long company there in Houston I got
to get the biggest dually truck whatever
and the nicest mowers but there's stuff
right stuff that we can go sell or that
it's hard to hide because it's sitting
right here
right there's that
or there's somebody buying hotel rooms
and purses and small trips for other
people on a credit card
and that happens and you don't get
caught and then it happens again you
don't get caught and it happens again
and suddenly you're running
um some businessy debt-ish sort of-ish
and you're running some personal life
stuff and we're going to the baseball
game and we're doing some stuff and I'm
gonna be out later I can't come home
this weekend or we're going to this
thing over the weekend the jobs got
crazy so I'm just getting hotel and I'll
be here tonight and those things happen
year after year after year and all of a
sudden somebody goes to get a loan for a
small thing and it's huge
I hope beyond all hope I'm wrong on that
okay
I hope I'm wrong
but something tells me you know you
haven't got the full story on that money
and something tells me you haven't
trusted him for a long long time so the
only person I can I can
say anything to it's you because you're
on the phone
and so I'm gonna ask you like a super
direct question what do you need to see
with your own eyes
so that you can exhale because you
haven't exhaled in months and months and
months if not years
is it text messages is it bank
statements what do you need to see
yeah I mean honestly I've I've been more
upset about this relationship with this
other woman than I ever did about the
finances why why
I don't know I guess because I found the
Ramsey plant it was like there was a
there was a plan to fix it there was a
path
you know but it but he was never up
enough about the dishonesty
I'm sorry he was never up enough about
the dishonesty
like okay so you've got the money thing
you've got the emotional affair with the
co-worker and
that's not right it happens all the time
right so I mean it's a oh it's it's not
a deal breaker in a relationship it's
not a it's not a marriage deal breaker
it's not a dating deal breaker those
things happen we sit down we work
through them
um and we figured them out okay so I'm
not minimizing that at all but also you
would not be calling me and saying is
this thing over how do I come back from
this if it was just that
if it was just a few months he was close
to somebody at work they shared a few
laughs they got they exchanged texts and
they probably shouldn't exchange started
hiding stuff
um like that wouldn't lead to this
so there's something else going on what
else do you feel he's not honest with
you about fully
well I mean a few weeks ago
or I guess about a month ago we came to
Austin for the ultimate conference
and he's been doing
um a bunch of side work to help pay off
all this debt and so he's been working a
lot in a single woman's home
and so I got insecure and was asking
questions about their relationship and
you know is she attractive and those
kinds of things
and then not two days later I find
deleted text messages between them where
he had taken my insecurities and shared
them with her
that sucks
was it in a mocking way kind of making
fun of you a little bit or or were
getting caught
it was well I'm
I mean her text message that said um
something along the lines of like you
know thinking about your wife's
questions I I would never you're an
honest family man I would never you know
interrupt your precious family
and so apparently he told her that like
when we were in Austin
she came up and I started asking how if
she was pretty and you know according to
him he just wanted to make sure that the
professional lines were there which is
BS but that's the story you know that's
not true
yes I do
okay but that's all I'm able to get out
so do you just gonna settle
I don't know
it was really dealt with
and so there's just a lot of layers yeah
did he ever agree to go to marriage
counseling with you
we have our second session on Thursday
okay what was the first session like
just introductory
yeah okay
here's what I would do if I was you I'm
just trying to fast forward myself and
like pick myself up and put myself in
your shoes
and I'm with somebody that I built a
life with I'm with somebody that I love
they've been at this point how old are
you
37. okay you've known him longer than
you haven't known him right
yeah like he's one of your arms and one
of your legs at this point
and so it's hard to face the truth about
that
but here we are
and I would write down I would spend a
couple of days writing down where are
the things if I go back over the last 5
or 10 or 15 years where are the things
that something came up and my first
thought was that's not right
but I just blew it off
I just passed it over
I didn't dig it any further
I want you to write those things down
and here's the key
he opened the door
with his financial infidelity and I'm
using that word intentionally
he was deceitful he cheated on you with
money and it impacts you because your
name is on all the things
and it impacted your refi it impacted
this dream of owning land that you had
and then he told you he had another plan
he was working on it and you come to
find out he not only lied about having a
plan he dug the hole deeper
and then he had an emotional affair with
somebody at work
and then you went with your intuition
you trusted that gut you that voice in
your gut and you called him out on
somebody at work uh some woman's house
he's working in
and he clearly had some sort of
secondary conversation with her that
would seemed strange and off book and he
wanted to make sure you didn't see it
and those are just the few you've told
me about in these five minutes
and I want you to write those things
down and when you sit down with a
therapist I want you to say
I can't go forward in this marriage
until I get some truthful answers and I
don't feel like you've been telling me
the truth for a long long time
because you and him can come up with all
the new conversation strategies and
communication strategy and all this
stuff but you are you don't feel like
the ground underneath you is solid right
I can hear it in your voice you think
you're crazy
you're not crazy
you've been moved around and shuffled
and kind of pushed to the side here you
kind of been treated like you're dumb
for a long time
she's too dumb
and I don't think you're dumb
is that fair
and here man I will say this I'll I'll
preach a squire he can call me I'd love
to have him on the show
and if I'm wrong about every step of the
way if he just found himself in a scary
deep shameful hole when it came to money
and he just kept digging and the hole
kept getting bigger I've sat with those
guys and that happens that's true
and he hated who he'd become he was
ashamed of himself and then he found
somebody at work that laughed at his
jokes and suddenly he's sharing stuff
and confiding in somebody else it's not
his wife because his wife is a call back
to how that happens that those two
things happen it happened with some
regularity and I'm not going to beat
somebody up for those moments but we got
to take some radical action to change
him
but what you're telling me is something
that sounds different
Fair
yes
why are there tears coming
because I mean that's exactly how I feel
I mean I feel like he just thinks that
I'm stupid and that he can just keep
you know
getting away with things but then also I
know that like
there when I got diagnosed there was
like a big shift in our relationship
you know why he thinks that
you can get away with things
why does he think that one
because he did for so long I guess I
don't know yeah because he can
because he can
and he'll just delete the messages and
when you find the deleted messages he'll
call you crazy and you're nuts and then
you're exhausted you got two kids and
the thought of anything
disruptive at this point is just too
it's just too much and so
I guess I'm just crazy I'm just gonna go
into the next day
and first it was the refi and then it
was the trip to Austin then it was the
hey let's buy some land and it's just
going to keep coming up and coming up
and coming up
at some point someone's got to turn the
lights on turn off the music and say the
dance is over
I need to know some the truth
we gotta be adults we gotta talk we
gotta be honest let's just get this all
out of here
so if I'm you
thankfully he agreed to go to marriage
counseling
hopefully it's not just a perfunctory
deal to get you off his back hopefully
he's actually interested in healing this
marriage
I would say those that the things you've
just told me here's the things that over
the course of our marriage feel like
you're not telling me the truth and
you've made me feel crazy for calling
throwing a flag on them I've got to know
the truth
and it may be that I want to see all the
financial records I want to see every
expenditure
all of them
and maybe I want to get every single
text message you've sent and all the
emails and all of this the WhatsApp and
all the signal I wanted to get all the
conversations
and also when I got diagnosed you
started treating me differently and I
feel less than
let's get to the bottom of it let me
just say this I don't think you're crazy
Lynn
I think you've ignored that voice in
your chest for so long
and now she's screaming at you we're not
safe we're not safe we're not safe we're
not safe maybe for the first time in a
long time let's listen to that voice
let me know how the uh trip or the cut
to the conversation with the counselor
goes and I'll walk with you every step
of the way thanks for your call thanks
for being brave